hi bret and heather
thanks for answering my ayahuasca
question last week you mentioned that
humans aren't the only species that
expresses gender
what other species also do it and how
please
uh so i thought this just warranted a a
a quick mention that um
the way that i've been defining gender
and the way that it fits
for me uh with all of the manifestations
that i've seen
um people use it is that it is
effectively the behavioral expression of
sex
and that in every animal that's
non-human and all the non-human animals
um that what we call that is sex role
and so there are um there are sex roles
that species from you know anemone fish
to sea horses to
antelope to elephant seals to dolphins
and
umbrella birds um you know have and they
are sex specific
uh so um we don't call it gender in
other species
uh but it is it is if it if if gender is
the behavioral expression of sex
uh then um then you're going to have
you're going to have that happen anytime
you've got um
behavior which is certainly all mammals
and birds and
probably all vertebrates and a
tremendous number of inverts as well
tremendous number of
insects so i would um i have been
defining
gender differently i've said it as the
software of sex in which case
gender will be found in
birds and mammals to a substantial
degree
but but differing degrees within those
clades and not much
found outside of them so i guess there's
a question about which definition of
gender
we're going with now i think that's i
mean that's that's interesting because
those
um i like both of those definitions
um behavioral expression of sex which is
the one that i've been saying for years
and
have you know written into pieces that
i've written and you're saying the
software of sex and they are
overlapping but not completely and um
and so they do they do have different
ramifications
for how you view say uh the stereotyped
lordosis behavior of a female
lizard um uh you know is that is that
gender or not it would be by my
definition but not by yours
um but it but the overlap i think is um
pretty much perfect when it comes to
humans like we all right
no variance so just so people know why
we're
the difference is immense between these
two definitions because most
um critters will not have gender because
most critters don't meet their parents
and therefore whatever sex
role they have will be programmed in at
a genetic level if behavior is
stereotyped
then it doesn't count um as gender by
your definition
right and so the point about it being
you know if you accept that it is the
software of sex and the point is
software is
vastly more flexible than hardware
you know in a lizard that doesn't meet
its parents and exhibits the stereotyped
behaviors
um you know there isn't a lot of
flexibility because in order for the
creature to be functional
that stuff had to be written in and the
fact that it is written in is amazing in
so many creatures but
um but the vast majority will have
nothing that we would call
um software it's much more like you know
maybe firmware it's programmed by
the genes and um all but unalterable
[Music]